[Musique]
10 juin 40 les troupes allemandes ont
passé la somme
les armées françaises sont en route
déclarez villes ouvertes paris tombe le
14 juin
l'avancée allemande et fulgurante
pliant la terrible percée 2 millions de
Parisiens prennent le chemin de l'exode
dans ses colonnes on retrouve une foule
désordonnée refluent vers on ne sait où
des familles portant leurs enfants à
bout de bras soutenant leur vieillard
emportant les quelques valeurs qu'elles
ont pu rassembler
l'arrivée des Allemands n’est cependant
pas une mauvaise nouvelle pour tout le
monde
remontant à contre-courant cette marée
humaine trois hommes se dirigent vers la
capitale
deux sont des espions allemands le
troisième et français
il s'appelle Henry Chamberlin c'est un
repris de justice
un voyou
dans à peine un an sous le nom de Henri
Laffont il sera l'un des chefs de la
Gestapo à Paris une police d'un genre
spécial dans laquelle on retrouve les
plus dangereux criminels de l'époque
arrestation de Juifs et de patriote
trafic vol torture assassinat
nous sommes en juin 1940
la pègre a choisi son camp
[Musique]
alors qui est Henri Laffont Henri
Laffont est né en 1902 dans le 13e
arrondissement à Paris c'est un pauvre
gosse il a une enfance malheureuse qui
le conduit assez inévitablement sur le
chemin de la petite délinquance donc il
est très rapidement repéré évidemment
par la police ce qui le conduit en
colonie pénitentiaire jusqu'à sa
majorité
donc Henri Laffont au moment de la
débâcle française à 38 ans il a passé
près de la moitié de sa vie en colonie
pénitentiaire ou en prison et il est
précisément justement incarcéré au
moment où intervient la chute de la
République au moment où les armées
allemandes enfoncent le front français à
ce moment là il est en prison à Paris
mais on soustrait l'ensemble des
prisonniers à l'avance allemande en
faisant reculer en fait ces prisonniers
au fur et à mesure que les Allemands
progressent dans le territoire en juin
40 il est incarcéré avec des espions
allemands ce qu'on appelle la cinquième
colonne des espions allemands infiltrés
en France avec qui il va s'échapper et
c'est là en fait que sa vie va changer
parce que lui qui n'était a priori qu'un
qu'un petit voleur qu'un petit escroc
condamné à la marginalité à vivre à
subir une vie finalement sans relief
cette rencontre qu'il fait avec ses
agents allemands va radicalement changer
la donne puisque il va remonter à Paris
avec ses agents qu'il va guider lui
c'est l'enfant du territoire c'est le
français qui va les aider à passer vers
la capitale pour rejoindre évidemment
les nouveaux maîtres de Paris et ces
gens là vont lui présenter évidemment
leur supérieur et c'est à partir de ce
moment là que il va devenir un agent
allemand
[Musique]
la Gestapo c'est donc la police de
sécurité du rage qui va au fil du temps
assumer une fonction de police
politique pourrait-on dire et cette
police politique va se charger de la
répression de toutes les forces qui
menacent la sécurité intérieure du Reich
[Musique]
les Allemands ne sont pas assez nombreux
en France pour tenir ce pays sans avoir
recours à des auxiliaires recrutés
localement c'est ce que Hitler a
théorisé dans mannekampf sous le
l'expression de participation indigènes
c'est relais
forcément on va les trouver chez des
gens qui sont prêts à se vendre
qui sont prêts à devenir des trades qui
n'ont pas d'autres patries finalement
que celle de l'argent et évidemment les
gens du milieu correspondent assez bien
à ce profil sont pas des gens politisés
sont des gens qui n'agissent que pour
eux ou pour leur groupe ils vivent en
marge de la société ils ne partagent pas
le destin de leur concitoyens déjà au
départ il se positionne comme étant des
ennemis de la société et donc évidemment
passer d'ennemis de la société à traître
finalement le pas est aisément
franchissable pour ces gens que que la
morale n'étouffe pas
il va travailler avec eux leur fait des
propositions sa proposition est assez
simple donc alors il va il va servir de
délateur il va faire de la provocation
de l'entrisme mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'il va proposer aux
Allemands mais moi petite Truant mais
j'en ai vu plein en prison vous savez ce
sont des gens qui condamnation à perpète
ou très lourde
si vous leur donnez quelques pouvoirs et
surtout la possibilité de faire des
bénéfices à gauche et à droite ce sont
des gens qui vous serviront extrêmement
fidèlement
[Musique]
dès juillet 40 ça fait à peine un mois
qu'il s'est mis au service des Allemands
il se présente à la prison de Fresnes et
il exige la libération d'un certain
nombre de prisonniers et de façon tout à
fait extraordinaire enfin c'est un
paradoxe qui s'explique par l'esprit du
temps mais l'administration
pénitentielle ne va pas s'opposer à
cette démarche qui pourtant n'est pas
une démarche officielle qui n'est pas
une démarche officiellement soutenue par
les Allemands et qui se fait comme ça de
gré agréer Lafont arrive à la prison de
Fresnes et exige il montre une carte de
police évidemment il est accompagné de
deux sous-officiellement et il exige
qu'on libère des prisonniers parmi ces
30 prisonniers on a essentiellement des
demi-sel c'est-à-dire des gens qui
forment ce qu'on peut appeler la base de
la pègre de la base pègre des gens qui
sont des escrocs des petits escrocs la
petite semaine mais qui sont très
intéressants ces gens une fois
éparpillée dans Paris vont pouvoir
ramener au chef en tout cas à celui qui
se pose désormais comme étant le chef
c'est à dire Henri Laffont toutes sortes
d'affaires et puis ils vont être ses
oreilles ils vont être ses oreilles ses
yeux dans les bars dans tous les voilà
ils vont pouvoir faire remonter les
informations
[Musique]
pour pouvoir devenir ce que les
Allemands appellent un veman un homme de
confiance il faut évidemment faire la
preuve de son attachement à la cause
nazie la fond n'est pas un nazi la
France est juste un opportuniste mais
s'il veut pouvoir profiter des larges
allemandes il faut bien qu'il montre
qu'il est engagé dans cette guerre à
leur côté on est juste après l'épisode
de la libération de Fresnes Léo gradé
allemand de la capitale ont assez mal
pris cet épisode parce que la fond
encore une fois n'avait pas été mandatée
pour cela et on est quand même face à
l'armée allemande des officiers dans la
tradition prussienne respectueux dans
certains ordre et la fois à ce moment-là
on est en juillet 40 la France à ce
moment là est au bord de se faire
arrêter et donc la fond apprend que les
Allemands aimeraient bien mettre la main
sur responsable des services de
renseignement belge qui s'appelle
Lambrecht qui s'est réfugiée en France
en zone libre c'est-à-dire hors de leur
portée l'un des prisonniers qu'il a
libéré Adrien qui est originaire a vécu
longtemps en tout cas à Bordeaux il y a
des grosses connexions à Toulouse
Toulouse qui est précisément la ville où
s'est réfugiés l'embracht et la font
l'histoire paraît invraisemblable la
fond fait un raid tout simplement il
prend sa voiture
il se rend à Toulouse il apprend par des
membres du milieu local ou se cachent
l'embrèche il fera pas sa porte et il la
Somme et il le met dans le coffre de sa
voiture il remonte à Paris avec c'est
aussi simple que ça c'est abracadamantes
c'est même stupéfiant mais les choses
semblent bien cette passer de cette
manière là pour les Allemands l'effet
est exactement celui qu'on peut
ressentir à en écoutant cette histoire
il n'en reviennent pas et donc cette
arrestation de l'embray j'étais à deux
conséquences la première pour la fond
qui sans doute
devient un personnage intéressant aux
yeux de la haute hiérarchie allemande
qui se disent tient on a quand même
quelqu'un qui est pratique sous la main
et surtout la conséquence la plus
dramatique c'est évidemment pour
l'embrest et pour les services de
renseignement belge l'embrayage va être
maltraité et va être déporté et son
arrestation va amener l'arrestation de
plusieurs dizaines voire centaines de
membres des réseaux belges de
renseignements à travers l'Europe
donc on voit la nocivité d'un homme
comme la foi en travers cette cette
histoire dramatique on voit qu'un homme
peut faire ce mal là
[Musique]
ici France actualités des nouvelles de
toute la France et de l'Empire
autour du Maréchal Pétain le pays se
retrouve avec l'esprit nouveau son sens
oublié la tradition perdue la continuité
de son histoire et quand devant le chef
les milliers de légionnaires les Bron la
main pour se serment dont la simplicité
double la grandeur quand d'innombrables
voix diront nous jurons de continuer à
servir la France et le chef c'est
pétains qui dira acceptant une nouvelle
fois la lourde charge qu'il porte sans
faiblesse Jean renouvelle le serment
moi-même avec vous
les grandes déclarations les serments
masque une pénible réalité
à l'ombre des anciens héros un nouveau
système s'épanouit
les places sont libres pour qui accepte
de collaborer
le milieu français s'apprête à vivre
quelques-unes de ses plus belles années
[Musique]
il s'appelle Bonnie et ce bonnie a été
au moment de la faire Stavisky on l'a
traité de premier policier de France
[Musique]
1934 l'escroc Alexandre Stavinski
détourne 200 millions de francs du
Crédit Municipal de Bayonne le scandale
dégénère en affaires d'État et le 6
février les likes fasciste marche sur
l'assemblée
qui en réunissant des preuves permet de
faire progresser l'enquête et de calmer
les esprits pour ce dernier ce fut un
moment de gloire en fait c'est un ripoux
Bonnie comme il en existe quelques-uns
dans la police il a été révoqué et il a
monté comme la plupart de ses collègues
évoqués une officine de police privée
vous savez spécialisé dans la
provocation le divorce l'adultère etc et
pour lui c'est son bâton de maréchal et
c'est un bon flic Bonnie les ripauds les
sabres et il va apporter à la Gestapo de
la rue Lauriston une efficacité
qu'aucune des autres gestapoora
les Allemands ont un plan évidemment
quand ils présentent Lafont à Bonnie ils
ont un plan l'idée c'est d'associer d'un
côté l'instinct du prédateur de la fond
le voyou le voyou qui a des connexions
dans le milieu qui qui a montré sa son
allégeance aux nouveaux maîtres de de
Paris et de l'autre côté le la rigueur
de l'administrateur la rigueur de
l'enquêteur bonus et l'homme qui va
créer des dossiers c'est l'homme qui va
créer un fichier alpha numérique c'est
l'homme qui va s'occuper de toute
l'intendance de la maison rue Lauriston
c'est à dire que c'est lui qui va
notamment s'occuper de la caisse de la
trésorerie de la rue Lauriston c'est
l'homme aussi qui va participer aux
interrogatoires il sait très bien
interroger évidemment il a été formé
pour ça et donc cette rencontre que le
entre Bonnie et la font et voulu par les
Allemands soutenu par les Allemands
encouragés par les Allemands à tel point
que ces deux-là vont former un binôme et
rentre d'ailleurs dans la postérité sous
le nom de groupe bony Laffont la
guestapo la rue Lauriston dite carlingue
est aussi appelé le groupe Bonnie Lafont
même si Bonnie n'est que le second de la
font et ne sera jamais que le second de
la font
[Musique]
le recrutement des membres de la de la
bande de la rue Lauriston va ne va pas
cesser tout au long de la période la
fond va recruter en fait tous les
talents qui viennent à lui et on va
quand même observer une montée en
puissance on voit qu'il va quand même
recruter des gens de plus en plus
menaçants inquiétant des vrais ennemis
de la société au sens qu'on donnait
alors à cette à cette expression
[Musique]
alors il faut en citer quelques-uns
dis-je dit le mammouth le Bel Abel
bibile Buffalo Bill d'ailleurs c'est sur
nous on dit quelque chose le mammouth
c'est un costaud Buffalo Bill il tire il
tire à tout va c'est quelqu'un qui est
toujours armé une note de police se
présente à l'époque comme extrêmement
dangereux toujours armé ne pas
l'appréhender attendre les renforts donc
c'est quelqu'un c'est quelqu'un de très
dangereux à belles danos et c'est une
légende déjà dans le milieu c'est un ami
intime de
Loutrel pierre loutrelle qui va rentrer
dans l'histoire du grand banditisme sous
surnom de Pierrot le fou il connaît
joachia qui le futur roi du non-lieu il
connaît intimement George buschet dit le
gros Joe c'est un ami évidemment des
Émilie buisson dit l'insaisissable qui
va devenir l'ennemi public numéro 1 donc
avec Abel Dano on est tout de suite dans
la très très haute voyoucratie et on est
tout de suite dans ce milieu cette crème
du milieu
[Musique]
un autre personnage très important qui
va rentrer rue loriston c'est un
personnage absolument considérable qui
s'appelle Jean Sartor Dijon le chauve
qui est considéré par les rapports de
police de l'époque comme un temps un
seigneur du milieu c'est-à-dire que cet
homme a atteint un statut dans le milieu
qui fait de lui l'un de ses chefs c'est
un homme qu'on peut considérer comme
l'un des 10 plus grands voyous de son
époque Jean Sartor dit Jean le Chauve va
bien évidemment comme l'ensemble des
voyous apprendre que le rhume Lauriston
il se passe quelque chose que là-bas il
y a un chef qui peut arranger les choses
et il va se mettre au service de cette
structure pour tout simplement pouvoir
développer ses propres trafics en
reversant bien entendu la dîme qu'on
doit au chef c'est à dire la dîme qu'il
doit à la fois
[Musique]
le lendemain je l'ai retrouvé le restant
c'est lui qui l'uniforme
tu viens avec l'oseille on efface tout
regarde moi quand je te cause
mais si tu sais encore de me doubler
merci patron
chez la mamie c'est la caisse dans la
semaine sinon c'est toi qu'on les fasse
dégage
un très bon copain Léon gabinet Léo pour
les dames
partager la même cellule à Fred il n'y a
pas si longtemps tu étais tombé pourquoi
c'est un violon on dirait pas comme ça
mais connais pas sa force en plus il est
un peu fêlé
présentement il est dans la banane
alors qu'est-ce que c'est qu'être un
gestapiste de la rue Lauriston ça veut
dire d'abord avoir ce que on appelle
dans l'argot des du mi-temps du milieu
le carton le carton c'est un Housewives
très particulier sur lequel il est écrit
que le possesseur de cette carte ne doit
en aucun cas être inquiété non seulement
par les les Allemands les autorités
allemands etc mais qu'il peut même les
réquisitionner à sa demande c'est à dire
qu'il peut obtenir l'aide des Allemands
qu'ils soient policiers soldats ou autre
ces deuxièmement la possibilité dans un
pays où il n'y en a plus
même la gendarmerie allemande des fois
en manque il y a plus d'essence et bien
d'avoir des bagnoles et de l'essence
sans problème et puis c'est la
possibilité d'avoir des armes et
qu'elles armes à des armes modernes
pistolet mitrailleurs schmesser quand
c'est pas carrément des Beretta puis en
face on a les flics officielles
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un flic officiel
ben ils ont pu d'essence pour leur
bagnoles ils sont armés de 6,35 le
français ou Manu France vous savez la
portée 10 mètres et puis ils sont comme
tous les Français ils sont pétris de de
crainte quand ce n'est pas de terreur
face à des gens qui disent même avec un
accent Corse police allemande Gestapo
[Musique]
désormais ils pourront aller cambrioler
ce sera une perquisition ils pourront
aller voler ce sera une saisie ils
pourront aller racketter ce sera tout
simplement une mise à l'amende quasiment
officielle comme si un procès-verbal
avait été établi donc on est là dans une
inversion des valeurs qui correspondent
plus généralement au temps de guerre les
temps de guerre sont effectivement le
moment d'un affaissement moral
[Musique]
de l'océan glacial Arctique jusqu'à la
mer Noire soit sur un fond de près de
3000 km les forces allemandes ont pris
position
la lutte pour la défense de l'Occident
est engagée la plus grande offensive qui
est jamais été menée au cours de
l'histoire et commence
bientôt malgré la résistance des 160
divisions de l'armée rouge les
frontières sont passées sur tous les
points
en France aussi la guerre continue une
guerre secrète dans laquelle les
traîtres sont à l'honneur pour la font
c'est le temps du triomphe dominateur il
sait se faire obéir craindre et
respecter son audace et son charisme
vont lui permettre de se rapprocher du
pouvoir
la France au petit truand devient l'un
des personnages les plus influents de
France parce qu'il a des connexions avec
les plus hauts gradés allemands en
France Lafont devient quelqu'un
d'important c'est une revanche
formidable pour lui lui qui a connu
finalement une vie assez misérable
jusqu'en 40 devient un homme que les
puissants veulent connaître il va
commencer à fréquenter enfin c'est tout
à fait incroyable quand on y pense il
fréquente Laval Laval le tutoie il
fréquente Bousquet le secrétaire général
de la police il fréquente à mes début
Bussières le préfet de police et tous
ces gens pourquoi fréquent-ils la font
pourquoi bah parfois cette rival parfois
c'est parce que la fond
peut leur trouver de la nourriture c'est
aussi simple que ça par exemple boimer
le Bourgue le chef de la Gestapo en
France Carl boemelbourg passe par Lafont
pour se nourrir que nos reines acceptent
des cadeaux de la fontaine qui est quand
même le numéro 2 de la police de
sécurité allemande en France
c'est-à-dire l'un des personnages les
plus puissants présents sur notre
territoire à cette époque là il se fait
livrer régulièrement des cadeaux ils
reçoivent sans doute un peu d'argent en
liquide etc Laval vient à lui pour
obtenir la libération de deux personnes
c'est avéré parce que le but
ultime de la font c'est bien entendu de
se dégager de la tutelle allemande c'est
bien des entendus d'être le plus
indépendant possible dans son activité
et en rendant des services de cette
nature là et on démontrant sa puissance
même si elle n'est que provisoire il
montre à la fois l'intérêt qu'il y a à
le connaître et l'intérêt à le laisser
dans cette position là on est dans un
dans un moment de l'histoire de France
où dans ce basculement là qui autorise
ces rapprochements là qui autorise qu'un
malfrat tue le président du conseil
c'est lamentable mais c'est évidemment
l'une des leçons aussi de cette période
c'est certainement ça aussi l'une des
leçons c'est que
on assiste à une inversion totale des
valeurs en fait les valeurs ou
sont-elles dans tout ça
[Musique]
il faut quand même dépendre un peu ce
système l'armistice qui a été signée par
par les autorités françaises et
allemandes prévoyaient que la France
livre un certain nombre de marchandises
il y avait des quotas qui étaient fixés
et que par ailleurs la France paye au
titre des frais d'occupation des sommes
absolument extravagantes anormalement
extravagante qui ne correspondait aucune
réalité
et aucune réalité économique puisque il
devait payer la France devait payer 20
millions de riches marques par jour au
titre des frais d'occupation 20 millions
de richements c'est à dire 400 millions
de francs donc évidemment les Allemands
ils vont très vite être tentés de
spéculer sur cet argent en le
réinjectant dans les canaux économiques
français pour obtenir en échange des
marchandises des marchandises qui vont
lui permettre qui vont permettre à
l'Allemagne de faire marcher à plein
régime son économie de guerre puisqu'on
est dans une guerre totale pour cela ils
doivent évidemment trouver les stocks et
ils doivent aussi proposer des tarifs
suffisamment attrayants pour que les
vendeurs viennent à eux et leur propose
leur marchandises donc en fait ils vont
le marché noir qu'on décrit et que les
Allemands eux-mêmes combattaient ils en
sont quasiment les instigateurs
[Musique]
les Allemands vont utiliser ces circuits
parallèles grâce aux sommes
considérables dont ils disposent pour
faire main basse sur des richesses
nationales
richesse nationale qui vont des métaux
non ferreux ont vain et dans cette
galaxie vous allez avoir ce qu'on
appelle des bureaux d'achat qui ont une
existence semi-officielle qui sont
alimentées par ces ressources parfois
officielles parfois qui ne le sont pas
et qui permettent donc à l'Allemagne
d'acheter énormément sur le marché
français ce qui garantit également aux
intermédiaires des marges très juteuses
en intervenant dans ces processus les
agents de la Gestapo française vont se
révéler d'excellents commerçants
des intermédiaires inquiétants prêts à
tous les mauvais coups des prédateurs
voraces à l'affût des bonnes occasions
pour eux c'est le temps des affaires des
marchés douteux et de l'argent facile
[Musique]
le rôle qui va être confié au groupe
bony Lafont ça va être d'abord de
sécuriser ses transactions parce
qu'évidemment on est là dans un univers
un peu gris plein de margoulins qui
peuvent être tentés d'escroquer les
autorités d'occupation dans un second
temps leur action va s'orienter vers le
commerce en tant que tel c'est-à-dire
qu'on va leur demander d'aller à la
recherche des stocks et de trouver les
stocks et de en fait s'intercaler en
tant qu'intermédiaire dans ces trafic
entre un vendeur qui est parfois n'est
pas d'ailleurs ne serait pas vendre mais
la font est convaincant
un vendeur et puis l'acheteur final qui
sont les autorités d'occupation ce sont
des trafics très simples puisque dans
les bureaux d'achat on me demande rien à
nos vendeur on demande ni son identité
ni l'origine des marchandises donc
évidemment là on imagine toute la faune
qui est attirée par un trafic aussi
simple pas de mise de fond pas de stock
c'est la recette de la fortune
charitables sont autour des hérités et
dans le quartier des Halles une soupe
gratuite le redistribuée ici ceux qui
ont faim trouveront un repas substantiel
et aussi un peu de réconfort moral
à cette époque là les queues s'allonge
devant les magasins les biens se font
rares l'alimentation est compliquée à
obtenir les Français doivent passer par
le marché noir et dans le même temps
c'est Gestapo constitue des îlots de
prospérité au milieu de cette misère
ces groupes de Français qui travaillent
pour les Allemands et évidemment au
premier chef le groupe de la rue
Lauriston
vit dans une opulence formidable c'est
une époque absolument merveilleuse pour
ces gens-là ils sont ils font bombance
pendant que les autres crèvent la faim
rue Lauriston on fait fête sur fête le
champagne coule on est vraiment là dans
dans une idée de rattrapage ces gens qui
étaient des voyous des proscrits des des
relégables des condamnés la marginalité
finalement d'un seul coup on pignon sur
rue font à peu près tout ce qu'ils
veulent
Lafont multiplie les aventures
à des aventures avec les plus certaines
des plus belles femmes de Paris à
l'époque quelques mannequins notamment
de chez escaparelli ou Chanel on
retrouve aussi des starlettes dans
l'entourage de Corinne luchères qui
amène des starlettes avec elle rue
Lauriston les les artistes vont
s'encanailler rue Lauriston ont fait des
banquiers Tino Rossi vient ça fait pas
de lui un collabo ça fait lui quand même
quelqu'un qui participe très légèrement
et sans doute sans pleinement plein de
prendre conscience de la gravité des
choses ou de la dangerosité des gens qui
le fréquentent mais qui participent
quand même de ce système de fait
perpétuel les cabarets sont ouverts
fonctionnent très bien sous l'Occupation
et sont réservés à une certaine
clientèle qui est celle des collabos ou
des officiellement les maisons closes
tournent à plein régime sous
l'Occupation là aussi la font les
fréquentes les hommes de la sont les
fréquentes quand ils n'en sont pas
d'ailleurs les propriétaires en
sous-main les cabarets de Pigalle
Montmartre passent sous la coupe de la
fond
[Musique]
s
ce soir en chantant comme ça tout est ma
paume Palace notre étoile
ces années sont pour ces hommes de la
rue Lauriston et des années qui peuvent
se résumer de la manière suivante le
soir on fait la fête on s'amuse et le
jour on vend des marchandises ou des
hommes aux Allemands il faut quand même
prendre conscience de de
l'importance de ces activités Jean
Sartor Jean Sartor le truandange en
Sartor dit Jean le Chauve cet homme là a
reconnu après-guerre avoir participé au
pillage depuis de mille appartements mis
l'appartement en trois ans on est dans
un quasiment un appartement par jour
dimanche compris cet homme va fêter son
centième million de francs en 43 il va
faire une grande fête pour fêter à où il
invite tous ses amis des Gestapo et
quelques gradés allemands pour fêter son
100e million de francs collectés là on
prend quand même conscience des fortunes
qui sont réalisées et de l'impunité dans
laquelle ces fortunes sont réalisées
alors qu'elles sont à l'évidence
totalement d'origine totalement illégale
même pas illégal
immoral
évidemment pour pouvoir faire du
commerce avec les Allemands il faut
aussi faire de la répression pour leur
service et donc il y a une sorte de de
d'équilibre qui va se trouver comme ça
entre dans les Gestapo françaises et
évidemment rue Lauriston entre d'un côté
les affaires commerciales et la
répression et tout ça parfois se mélange
on peut faire des affaires commerciales
en faisant de la répression quand on va
arrêter et des agents alliés par acheter
généralement ces agents alliés par
acheter ont de grosses sommes d'argent
sur on les récupère à ce moment-là quand
on va intervenir chez un riche juif dans
le cadre de la politique antisémite
suivie par l'occupant à l'époque tout
est pris dans la maison jusqu'au prise
de courant si vous voulez ce système se
tient bien pour les Allemands il est
d'une grande efficacité parce que ces
agents ne leur coûte finalement rien
ils ont finalement des dizaines de
Français à leurs services dans les
guestapo françaises qui leur coûtent pas
un sou c'est l'agence se nourrissent sur
la bête quand ils arrêtent quelqu'un ils
le dépouille sont des loups
et c'est loups les Allemands leur mettre
une laisse ils s'en font des chiens de
garde
[Musique]
cette meute va traquer les résistants
harceler les Juifs
les truands deviennent policiers des
tranches policiers qui interviennent
hors de tout contrôle
intimidation abus de pouvoir violence
c'est le temps de la répression
la torture a toujours été utilisée comme
un moyen rue Lauriston pour forcer les
gens arrêter à parler c'était une tortue
qui n'était pas particulièrement
élaborée il s'agissait de tabassage à
coup de nerf de bœuf ou à coup de poing
ou de pieds ou de bastonnade parfois le
supplice de l'eau était utilisé
c'est-à-dire en fait qu'on prenait le
prisonnier et qu'on le plongeait dans
une baignoire en général remplie d'une
eau saturée d'imonie ça fait partie
aussi du processus d'humiliation des
victimes et on le plongeait dans l'eau
jusqu'à suffocation c'est extrêmement
éprouvant pour la personne qui en est
victime et en général les
évanouissements arrivaient très
fréquemment et pour réveiller les les
prisonniers on leur glissé entre les
dents à ce moment-là un mélange de savon
et d'essence
[Musique]
on est dans un dans un schéma de torture
qui qui se multiplie une nouvelle fois
et qui atteint en fait des paroxysmes
qui sont terrifiants extrêmement
choquants les prisonniers certains
prisonniers français ont expliqué après
avoir été arrêté par les hommes de la
font et avoir été ensuite remis aux
autorités allemandes qu'ils étaient
mieux traités par les Allemands que par
les français de la Gestapo
un des phénomènes de la torture c'est
d'abord cette espèce d'avilissement de
l'être que cherchait la Gestapo
au départ il voulait obtenir des aveux
parce qu'ils étaient extrêmement
formalistes et pointilleux il leur
fallait des aveux écrit enregistrer
noter et ensuite la justice expéditive
pouvait passer mais seulement après des
aveugles les aveux n'importe quoi
mettons que l'on veuille torturer pour
obtenir des renseignements mais je crois
que dans le cas de la Gestapo c'était
bien pire que ça c'était une espèce de
volonté sadique de de faire du mal
[Musique]
la rue Lauriston a excellé dans la lutte
contre les réseaux français alors on
introduit on fait de l'entrisme dans ces
réseaux et des gens qui vont évidemment
trahir l'organisation qu'ils ont pénétré
alors pour prendre des réseaux très
connus Allianz a subi plus de 400
arrestations Marco Polo qui est un
groupe de résistance
c'est de la résistance très liée à
Londres là c'est pareil un tombe
plusieurs fois trois fois l'état-major
de Marco Polo défense de la France et
également subit des arrestations et des
chutes énormes dont la plus emblématique
Geneviève De Gaulle qui est d'ailleurs
arrêté par Bonnie lui-même
[Musique]
les Allemands ont toujours été très
vigilants par rapport aux questions de
propagande c'est parce qu'ils prennent
la presse qu'on dessine au sérieux que
défense de la France qui est l'un des
journaux les plus importants de la
France captive est dans leur ligne de
mire
[Musique]
vous allez avoir une traque policière
c'est à dire que des individus vont être
arrêtés soit à leur domicile soit sur
leur lieu de travail des hommes de la
bande bunie Lafont weight postées rue
Bonaparte dans une librairie qui
s'appelle au vœu de Louis XII qui est la
boîte aux lettres principale du
mouvement de résistance c'est à dire là
oui le dépose des consignes là ils le
reçoivent des consignes etc etc
[Musique]
dans une enveloppe à déposer à déposer
je me dis je vais prendre le biclet de
mon père et puis il faut appuyer tu veux
pas tranquillement je pose ma bicyclette
de pas de la librairie et puis je me dis
c'est le rôle
la porte n'est pas fermée comme
d'habitude je ne sais plus exactement
quel détail et je me suis dit là bon
est-ce qu'il faudrait que je dis du coup
si on a peur parce qu'une porte est
comme si ou comme ça c'est pas la peine
de vous la continuer à faire des des
choses par ci pas là pour mieux
s'arrêter comme tu es pas parti pour
t'arrêter alors bah il faut le faire
alors j'ouvre la porte et là il y a
quelqu'un qui me qui me saute dessus je
sais pas si c'était pénible à fond mais
il y avait deux hommes qui étaient là et
qui m'emmènent directement dans
l'arrière boutique
[Musique]
quel est le bilan de cette opération en
gros une cinquantaine de membres sont
arrêtées 25 sont arrêtés au vœu de Louis
XII et l'autre moitié sur leur lieu de
travail ou à leur domicile
[Musique]
je vais passer la nuit du
la nuit du 20 juillet 43 en prison à
Fresnes et j'en suis sorti que le 20
janvier et là de partir en train pour
arriver directement pour une valve et
pour partir à un autre endroit qui est
un Autriche qui était matose
et chers amis
pour la quatrième fois la France célèbre
dans l'épreuve et la tristesse la
nouvelle de guerre Noël fête de la
Nativité
et la mort plane sur le monde entier et
la France subit chaque jour l'épreuve
cruelle de nouveau crime et l'immense
misère des bombes battements malgré tant
de désastres je garde ma foi dans
l'avenir de la France une fois de plus
je vous adjure de penser par-dessus tout
au péril de mort que couvrait notre pays
si sur lui s'abattait l'aïdose guerre
civile
les incantations n'y feront rien le vent
mauvais redouté par Pékin souffle chaque
jour plus fort sur la France les
maquillonsflent la résistance se
développe la fond le vautour s'imagine à
présent en aigle le voyou se rêve
général
143 le système du borodacha perd son
efficacité perd son sens devient moins
rentable pour les Allemands donc en fait
on observe un basculement beaucoup de
ces accrédités qui jusqu'à présent
étaient tantôt dans la répression tantôt
dans du commercial vont basculer vers
une activité plus spécifiquement
répressive c'est d'ailleurs menée très
concrètement des assauts contre des
mouvements de résistance
[Musique]
notre ami Laffont qui a l'énergie et
l'expérience propre à vaincre dans ce
genre de lutte propose de mettre sur
pied une brigade composée d'extérieur
nord-africain équipé et entraîné par ce
soir avec pour mission ramener le calme
et l'ordre dans les campagnes
notre seul objectif c'est la libre
circulation de notre troupe afin de
permettre le prélèvement de ce qui est
nécessaire à notre étendances et aux
besoins du peuple allemand
cher ami Laffont
si dans 10 ans 3 mois
l'exoncide n'est pas sûr nous
appliquerons au président français le
régime que nous appliquons en musique en
Russie et ça c'est clair
tout à fait que
boire un coup c'est du bon te casse pas
la tête avec ça je m'en occupé
la fond a pris goût au pouvoir il est il
est un chef de service de police
respecté craint il a une autre ambition
il a l'ambition de devenir un chef de
guerre et donc il a une grande idée à la
fin de l'année 43 il a l'idée de
mobiliser ou plutôt d'incorporer les
prisonniers nord-africains que les
Allemands détiennent depuis 1940 dans un
corps d'armée il a carrément cette
ambition et évidemment les les Allemands
ne peuvent finalement accueillir que
favorablement l'idée d'une troupe qui
viendrait sécuriser les arrières de leur
front
il s'agit d'une population pauvre peu
éduquée qui est constitué
essentiellement de manœuvre de
journaliers de garçons de barres on
trouve parmi eux quelques souteneurs
quelques délinquants on trouve aussi
quelques assassins donc on comprend très
bien pourquoi est-ce qu'il s'engage dans
la brigade nord-africaine c'est d'abord
d'abord et surtout pour avoir eux aussi
une carte et être à l'abri des
investigations de la police et là cette
occasion là il rejoignent l'Ordre Noir
et ils viennent des militaires SS à
cette occasion la font obtient le grade
de capitaine Bonnie et les cinq chefs de
section deviennent des lieutenants
pour les guestapists de la rue Lauriston
avec le temps des défaits du Reich vient
celui de la répression une répression
sauvage sans limite
il porteront le feu dans les provinces
frondeuses il brutaliseront il pilleront
il violeront
c'est le temps des massacres
on va essentiellement parler de son
activité en Corrèze et en Dordogne qui
au départ était une activité de
pacification de la zone va rentrer dans
une logique de terreur à défaut
d'attaquer les makis et d'en venir à
bout ils vont essayer de pacifier la
région par la terreur et à chaque fois
qu'ils vont intervenir il feront de la
même manière ils obéiront de la même
manière menaçant volant payant et
violent le cas échéant aussi il y a
beaucoup de viols évidemment donc là on
est il y a une horde sauvage qui s'abat
sur cette région
[Musique]
donc évidemment il se vautre
littéralement sur les populations
civiles et sur les gens qui les arrêtent
ils menace les pères de famille en leur
expliquant que si ils leur donnent pas
leurs économies toute la famille va être
déporté et ils en ont le pouvoir donc
évidemment on se retrouve face à des
populations totalement démunies sans
aucune protection face à ces fou furieux
il y a le cas par exemple là-dessus avec
mon ange et un autre membre de la
brigade nord-africaine qui agresse un
jeune homme dans la rue pour rien le
jeune homme passé ils veulent lui mettre
ils veulent l'arrêter contre les ses
papiers ils sont tous les deux ivrent et
le jeune homme simplement résiste il
veut pas donner son bras pour se faire
arrêter il se fait tabasser très
sévèrement avant de prendre une décharge
de fusil mitrailleur dans les jambes ils
veulent l'obliger à se relever et ce
malheureux ne peut évidemment pas se
relever il se fait encore tabasser il va
finir handicapé à vie pour rien cette
jeune homme n'était pas un résistant
[Musique]
on suit en fait au rouge le chemin de la
brigade nord-africaine en fait un chemin
qui est jalonné de de cris de peur et
qui pèse lourd à la sortie puisque on
voit qu'on a plus de 100 victimes
d'exécution sommaire faite par les gens
de la brigade dans africaine
[Musique]
ici France actualités nuit du lundi 5 au
mardi 6 juin 1944 nuits historique les
Anglo-Américains débarquent sur le solde
Normandie dans la nuit des milliers de
tonnes d'acier s'abattent sur les
navires ou pylône les défenses
allemandes les unités légères prennent
pieds sur le rivage et voici l'aube au
large l'impressionnante flotte en Glos
américaines
[Musique]
le 13 août 1944 les derniers éléments de
la brigade rentrent à Paris il faut dire
que la plupart étaient déjà rentré
Lafont était déjà rentré et écoeurée
d'ailleurs et que aurait pas de temps
par par l'activité de ces hommes mais
davantage par le sentiment de plus en
plus clair que la partie était perdue
[Musique]
les bombardiers
la plus massive qui est jamais préparée
une opération militaire les villes le
pays entier sont coventrisés comme
disait les Allemands car il ne faut
jamais oublier que ce sont eux qui ont
commencé eux qui se vantaient de tous
détruire quand il se croyait les plus
forts
tenter de s'enfuir leur idée première
c'est de rejoindre l'Espagne
malheureusement pour lui il part donc
avec Bonnie et leurs enfants et là il va
vivre ce que lui a fait vivre aux autres
il va tomber sur un barrage qui
évidemment va lui confisquer sa voiture
et il va demander au fils de Pierre Boni
Jacques Bonny de rentrer à Paris en vélo
pour demander de l'aide à un ami à eux
en tout cas quelqu'un qu'il croit être
un ami à eux un trafiquant en notoire
qui s'appelle Joseph jouannovici un
personnage très ambigu très complexe
résistant par ailleurs mais pas vraiment
un personnage tout en gris et Joseph
johannovici va balancer ses
anciens amis la font hé Bonnie et la
préfecture de police va envoyer des
hommes pour les cueillir on est en
septembre 1944
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le procès à fond va s'ouvrir très
rapidement puisque dès décembre 1944
l'ensemble des membres de la rue
Lauriston qui ont été arrêtés vont être
conduits devant le tribunal on est quand
même juste trois mois après leur
arrestation ça veut dire que on est dans
une instruction qui a été faite dans un
temps record trop rapide d'ailleurs ça a
énervé les forces de police qui
s'occupaient de l'enquête on sent qu'il
y a eu sur cette affaire une pression et
une pression notamment très particulière
des services de renseignement français
l'opinion publique par ailleurs exigeait
des têtes il fallait tuer les traîtres
et là on avait les traîtres parfaits il
passe donc en jugement et sont tous
exécutés ils sont neufs à être conduit
au Pelton d'exécution un matin de
décembre 1944 fin de la rue Lauriston
exécution de ses meneurs
au palais de justice à Paris de traîtres
ont été condamnés à mort pour avoir
prêté aux Allemands une aide ignoble la
font et Bonnie que vous voyez en
uniformalement les traîtres ont été
condamnés à être fusillés par un peloton
d'exécution composé de FFI
[Musique]
quelle erreur d'avoir un fusillé ces
gencives alors qu'ils avaient tant de
choses à nous dire faut penser qu'ils
ont été fusillés des décembre 44 vous
imaginez la guerre va encore durer 7
mois je dirais que peut-être on les a
fusillés d'autant plus vite qu'on avait
pas trop envie
qu'il raconte des choses il y aurait
peut-être eu des mensonges bien sûr mais
je pense qu'il savait quand même un
certain nombre de choses un certain
nombre de personnalités qui
auront un certain déroule des rôles
politiques ou autres sous la Quatrième
République ne sont pas tout à fait
blancs bleus vis-à-vis par exemple de la
font et de la Gestapo de la rue
Lauriston
[Musique]
quant à la pas la pietaille parce que
c'était des types impressionnants qui
ont des meurtres et des tortures sur la
conscience des chutes de réseau de
résistance ou autre beaucoup se sont
recyclés après guerre alors le passage
de la guerre à l'après-guerre pour eux
c'est fait par le biais de la résistance
un grand nombre qui avait ce sentiment
venir et qui en plus avaient été plus ou
moins embauché par des réseaux de
résistance pour leur spécialités
professionnelles notamment l'exécution
en plein air public comme ça au milieu
des gens ça se s'approvise pas on avait
besoin de tueur on embauchait des tueurs
et bien un certain nombre grâce à ce
biais de la de passage par la résistance
vont échapper à la police et vont
échapper à la justice d'une certaine
manière et ce qui est très intéressant
c'est de voir que ces gens-là ont pris
des habitudes d'impunité d'argent de
grosses bagnoles d'efficacité de
maniement de d'armes qui sont quand même
des armes de guerre et ce sont eux qui
vont constituer le milieu des années
d'après-guerre
on peut difficilement ne pas citer le
cas record Auguste Ricord qui sera
bientôt connu dans dans le milieu
international cette fois-ci sous le
surnom de elviro le vieux quel est son
rôle pendant l'occupation au côté de la
fond il en fait il s'occupe des équipes
qui raquettes les établissements de
plaisir de Pigalle et des Montmartre en
tout cas Auguste Ricord passe par
l'Espagne et rejoint l'Amérique latine
ou grâce à ses connexions dans le milieu
corse lui-même est corso marseillais il
va devenir un élément central ou en tout
cas l'une des têtes d'affiches de la
French Connection ou en tout cas de cet
ensemble de réseaux qu'on a appelé la
French Connection que d'ailleurs on
appelle de plus en plus la corsicane
connection ce sont déjà plus actions
fausses et sans preuve
et une accusation sans preuve elle peut
être niée sans preuve je suis arrivé à
la fin de la guerre en Argentine ou
aussitôt j'ai commencé à faire des
restaurants français il n'y en avait pas
ma seule chose qu'on peut me reprocher
c'est d'avoir une clientèle de
trafiquante de trafiquants
de toute façon
j'avais 14 ans et demi
et j'étais bonne année
et
comme on peut dire tentative de
tentative de meurtre
par ailleurs d'autres anciens gestapists
vont très bien savoir se recycler pierre
Loutrel dit Pierrot le fou va fonder
après-guerre au lendemain immédiat de la
guerre et en tout cas jusqu'en 45-46 ce
qu'on a appelé le gang des tractions
avant multipliant en fait les braquages
les attaques Camara armées de façon très
audacieuse ils sont d'ailleurs rentrés
dans la légende et qui est-ce qu'on
retrouve autour de lui dans son équipe
ses proches ses amis on retrouve Joe
Attia qui va devenir la décaïdes de
Paris jusque dans les années à la fin
des années 50 début des années 60 on
retrouve à beldanos le fameux mammouth
qu'on retrouve aussi Georges bouchache
qui va être un voyou d'une extrême
importance notamment dans les années 60
on retrouve d'une manière générale un
certain nombre de d'anciens peut-être
pas directement en gestapis mais des
gens qui étaient vraiment très proches
de cette structure qui parfois ont donné
des coups de main on les retrouvera dans
quasiment toutes les associations
criminelles de la prière
[Musique]
fuyant le peloton d'exécution la plupart
des truands de la Gestapo française se
disperse dans la nature on les retrouve
en Europe en Asie en Afrique ou encore
aux Amériques
cette éparpillement jette les bases
d'organisation internationale du crime
cigarette drogue Armes prostitution ils
sont dans tous les trafics se mélange de
renseignements se rapprochant
dangereusement du monde politique ils
interviennent partout
si les meneurs ont été mis hors d'état
de nuire en 1944
nombreux sont les prétendants prêts à
prendre la relève
beaucoup de cela sont passés par la rue
Lauriston à l'école d'Henry Lafont le
parrain de la Gestapo
[Musique]